[Musique]
les essentiels du
Sénat produit du tabac ou à base de
nicotine leverz l'écran de
fumée avec 75000 décès annuels le tabac
est la première cause de mortalité
évitable en France depuis une dizaine
d'années plusieurs produits du tabac ou
à base de nicotine sont présentés comme
des alternatives au tabac fumé supposé
réduire les risques sanitaires associés
au
tabagisme les cigarettes électroniques
qui n'utilisent pas de tabac
reproduisent les sensations d'une
cigarette traditionnelle tout en évitant
l'exposition aux substances toxiques
émises lors de la
combustion généralement rechargeable des
versions à usage unique appelé puuf pour
bouffer en anglais et visant une jeune
clientèle ont récemment fait leur
apparition en France moins répandu des
dispositifs électroniques utilisant du
tabac qui est chauffé mais pas brûlé
sont également
commercialisés enfin les tabacs à mâché
et à prisé ainsi que des sachets de
nicotine à sucé font également partie
des produits présentés comme étant à
risque réduit puisque leur consommation
n'implique pas de combustion mais ces
produits sont-ils réellement moins
nocifs que le tabac fumé dans leurs
notes scientifiqu fait au nom de
l'opexte l'Office Parlementaire des
choix scientifique et technologique
Gérard leeul député et Catherine
procassia sénateur regret un manque
d'étude disponible ne permettant pas de
conclure pour l'ensemble des produits
au-delà de l'évaluation de leur novité
intrinsèque des incertitudes entourent
l'impact de ces produits en tant
qu'outil de sevrage d'initiation ou de
maintien dans le tabagisme ce flou fait
l'objet de controversse sur les
politiques publiques à adopter les
rapporteurs jugent nécessaire de
conduire des études indépendantes à
l'échelle nationale pour consolider
l'état des connaissances et guider les
décisions législatives et réglementaires
si le sevrage est bien l'objectif à
atteindre une approche de réduction des
risques pourrait être préconisée à
l'instar du Royaume-Uni qui intègre la
cigarette électronique à sa stratégie de
lutte contre le tabagisme il recommande
également de fournir aux consommateurs
des information claire complète et
objective sur les connaissances et
incertitudes entourant ces produits il
propose notamment de mener une campagne
grand public de prévention sur les
risques associés au vapeaufumage qui
consiste à utiliser en même temps des
cigarettes traditionnelles et des
cigarettes
électroniques enfin les auteurs de cette
note souhaitent une meilleure régulation
de la commercialisation de ces produits
il se prononce en faveur de
l'interdiction des peufs et de certains
arômes visant spécifiquement les jeunes
il préconise de développer rapidement un
cadre réglementaire pour les nouveaux
produits orau de la nicotine et pour les
produits susceptibles d'émerger
prochainement pour en savoir plus
consultez le site Internet du
Sénat
y